if you loved hbo's dark teen drama
euphoria here are five other titles
worth checking out on this week's binge
guide
the hbo series that follows a group of
high schoolers navigating love and
friendships in a world of drugs
sex trauma and social media is coming
off a certified fresh first season along
with three emmy wins
including outstanding lead actress in a
drama series for the show's star
zendaya so while you wait for season 2
plus the upcoming film malcolm emery
from euphoria creator sam levinson and
starring zendaya
this list should give you all the feel
starting with our certified fresh pick
at the end of the effing world
based on a graphic novel by charles
forsman and preceded by a 2014 tv short
this netflix show with a pair of
certified fresh seasons is about
two confused teen outsiders who embark
on a road trip together
led by stars jessica brayden and alex
lother critics call the show a darkly
funny meditation on love
and trauma and proves that falling in
love can feel like the end of the effing
world
you can binge the first two seasons in
just under seven hours just don't use it
as a guide when planning
your next road trip and coming in with
our brand new pick this week is we are
who we are
recently joining euphoria on hbf this
coming of age story is about two
american teenagers who live on a u.s
military base in italy
and they're going through all the messy
exhilaration and anguish of being a
teenager
co-created and written by call me by
your name director luca guaranino
critics say he creates small screen
poetry in the show by focusing on the
little details and allowing its central
teams to just be
you'll be able to binge the first season
in around eight hours and then you may
or may not be all about that military
base life
and our editor's pick this week is the
hulu series love victor
set in the world of the 2018 film love
simon this certified fresh show follows
victor
a new student at his high school who is
on his own journey of self-discovery
while struggling with his sexual
orientation
the show stars michael cimino who
critics say charms in what is a sincere
and sweet spin-off with a lot of heart
and you can bench the first 10 episodes
in about five hours which means you'll
have plenty of time to check out the one
hour and 50 minute film
love simon as well and showing up as our
audience pick this week is the 2017 film
the greatest showman with an audience
score of 86 percent
this musical about the rise of pt barnum
and the barnum bailey circus has a
stacked cast that includes euphoria
zendaya along with hugh jackman rebecca
ferguson
and zac efron audiences love it for the
musical numbers and star power
while critics say this film tries hard
to dazzle the audience with a barnum
style sense of wonder but
at the expense of its complex subjects
far more intriguing real life story
if the hour and 45 minute binge time is
just too easy you can check out some
other past and daily projects like the
oa
and kc undercover and finally our
throwback pick this week goes to the
british drama series
skin running for seven seasons starting
in 2007
this show tells the story of a group of
british teens trying to grow up and find
love and happiness despite
questionable parenting and teachers the
unique show replaced its main cast
every two years helping kickstart the
career of nicholas holt along the way
and critics praised it for its addictive
authenticity and depictions of teenage
hood and all
its trainwreck glory it'll take you just
under 47 hours to binge skins and then
you can check out its playground rival
shirts
i'm kidding of course all right friends
hopefully this list will leave you
feeling just
euphoric please let us know what you are
currently streaming in the comments
and be sure to check out the new rotten
tomatoes is wrong a podcast from rotten
tomatoes because fresh and rotten is
just the beginning of the conversation
and new episodes drop
every thursday and if you don't want to
miss out on any future recommendations
based around the movies and shows that
you love be sure to hit that subscribe
button and notification bell and as
always we can't thank you enough for
watching this show and we hope to see
your face in the next video
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you